hello and welcome to pi data global 2021
my name is marisa winkles and i am very
happy to be here and be your host for
this keynote session i would like to now
welcome david beasley you may know david
as the author of the python cookbook the
python essential reference or the
recently published python distill
he is currently an independent
researcher and educator who teaches
advanced computer science courses which
you can find on his website
in today's keynote begin
and he will take us through a first-hand
oral history from the earliest days of
python in science and answer the
question how did we end up here
at the end we have approximately 10
minutes for q a so please feel free to
ask david your questions throughout the
talk
david the floor is all yours
okay thank you very much glad you're
glad to be here kind of mysterious title
uh begin end but
the uh you know the topic of this talk
is it's really why python like why did
python of all things
take over the world of science
that's a question that a lot of people
ask especially computer scientists
actually like to ask this question a lot
like how did this happen
and who let this happen because
sometimes they look at pythagoras just
like
it's a very unlikely story right a
language named after my python developed
on the side of this stuff how did it
take over science
and uh you know a common answer that is
sort of given for this is that people
use python because of the tools numpy
scipy pandas matplotlib and all that but
um
but where did that stuff come from
i mean that's an answer now you know why
python has become popular but what
happened before that how do things begin
and in some sense
this talk is a story about that it is a
personal story for me it is not the only
story but um i think i think it gives
some kind of insight into what people
are thinking and and
what was going on in kind of the
earliest days of python and science so
to start this off i'm gonna i'm gonna
time warp to 1994
and i'm gonna talk about lightning
strike and
in 1994
if you were really into a scientific
visualization you might have had a
silicon graphics workstation this is a
silicon graphics crimson it's about a 75
000 machine not cheap but this was the
thing to have on you on your desk i mean
this was great and so it was a little
bit unfortunate when ours got blown up
you know lightning storm one day and so
it so it got struck by lightning and
honestly i was kind of happy about that
i was i was like good i'm glad it got
struck by lightning now now now you're
looking at this date you've got some
kind of attitude problem i mean what
what's with you and not like wishing
harm on this on on this machine i mean
this is the machine to have this was
jurassic park
it was in the movie there it is it's
like in the movie the silicon graphics
workstation it was the thing that the
girl used to fly around unix if you know
the movie it's it's it's like
yeah i know unix this is great so why
you know why would you want harm on it
um and so
we had one of these machines this is um
this is our office the machine was
actually sitting over there in the
corner i didn't realize uh 25 years ago
that this photograph would be used in a
conference so it's not a very good
picture of the silicon graphics but
neil's so sad over there
and i sat here
on the sun workstation okay so you know
you might say oh okay dave's just
envious you know kind of the sun he
doesn't have the sort of graphics so
this is this is kind of the setup um
this was our fine facility this trailer
off the side of the road like looking at
that
lightning struck out in the parking lot
i actually remember the lightning strike
because we were trying to meet a paper
deadline
uh that day
and lightning struck the piper the
parking lot and it just so happened that
all the network cables for the machines
in the building were actually sitting on
the ground
literally on the ground underneath this
trailer and they sucked up the lightning
bolt and blew out all the network
interfaces so
um so you know i was like okay well that
was that was unfortunate and then and
then you can also look at this and just
say what kind of dump is this like where
is
where is the guy working in a trailer
what looks behind like a garbage
incinerator or something what where is
it where is this so
we're we're kind of over here
they don't even want to show us on the
picture of the place but the rest of the
laboratory is up on a mountaintop here
this is a big government facility um
department of energy big facility um i
actually spent most of my time
interacting with the beast which was
located in that building that i have
highlighted there now
a lot of my day-to-day time was spent
interacting with the beast basically uh
okay so you have the beast i would
submit batch jobs to the bees
and then the beast would run for three
to six hours or something like that and
produce a bunch of data files as it as
it turns out you can only schedule about
six hours on the beast at a time because
then other people would want to use the
beast
you got it so you would you would kind
of schedule batch jobs on that produce a
lot of data
i would then take all those data files
and
ftp them
over to my sun workstation over a 10
megabit connection maybe and then try to
store them on my local disk which is
not very big i mean you look at these
numbers keep in mind this 1993 okay so
like four gigabytes in 1993 was still a
lot of space so but it was you know it's
you know transferring data not a lot of
space i then have to fight meals over
that sgi
you know he's a postdoc and i'm like
okay so we'd get in some battle where
i'd use this machine if i had to
relocate over there and then after a few
hours or days of fooling around i would
get some nice pictures
and then kind of repeat the process
kind of painful to be honest
you know not not the smoothest workflow
but you did get some nice some nice
pictures out of it
like that i even have the picture here
i can fly it across the zoom it's like a
special effect yeah it's like okay so
you get some nice nice pictures pictures
out of the thing you might get a
magazine cover out of it and if you're
really i don't know really lucky maybe
even get on the news or something it's
like oh cbn news so there's there's some
picture i rendered on that sgi that
ended up on the news
so
it was really pretty
but it kind of was terrible to be honest
i mean i was really glad when the
machine got struck by light it was like
good you deserved it because it's like
this workflow is like terrible okay
now
part of the problem here is maybe
understanding what it called
dimensionality um
if i'm gonna make a plot of a thousand
data points
that's not really complicated i could do
that
if i wanted to amp it up to a thousand
by a thousand data points all of a
sudden i'm dealing with a million data
points this is i'm not sure that i can
really do a million data points on my
site on the workstation this this the
sgi could do that but probably not my
local desktop
if you go to like a thousand by a
thousand by a thousand you're up at a
billion data points
that is a little tricky to deal with and
in some sense this is the root of a lot
of the problems we had because we are
dealing with the beast
talk more about the beast later the
beast was basically a thousand
workstations
and that size let you solve kind of new
problems
but it introduced other constraints like
you know it's me expecting to do things
with that data set
was not going to work so
so this kind of the you know kind of the
setup you got the beast got data got
other things going on
i'm going to leave that behind for a
moment flash forward four years to
january 1998.
so
in january 1998
i
flew out to
maryland i actually saw guido and some
of the python developers out there and
um one of the uh one of the things that
i did is i visited nasa goddard
so this is nasa goddard and i gave a i
gave a talk out there this was partly
coordinated by some of the space
telescope
guys if you if you know about the space
telescope people they're very big into
python these days i've been often talk
about this so this was this is in the
end sort of 1998
and i remember giving a talk about
python and
one of the people in the talk they asked
this question um how did you get
permission to use python and it kind of
took me back actually i didn't i didn't
quite know how to answer this nobody had
ever asked this question before and and
so my my answer at the time
is i i just said well we didn't ask and
that did not go over well
people got angry actually a few people
in that talk got angry they're like it's
like who are you guys you didn't ask
what are you talking about like
and in preparing this talk i was sort of
i was sort of going back to that
question and thinking well why did i
answer it that way and
the answer the only thing that i could
come up with is that
we didn't exist it was not a matter of
permission it's that we didn't exist and
you can say
you didn't exist what is that about so
to understand that you kind of have to
understand government
funding of big science um in in 1992
there was and kind of in that period
there was a lot of emphasis on sort of
grand challenge high performance
computing this is the so-called blue
book it was basically from the
presidential budget of 1992 this was
something that was given to congress
okay so this is at high level
congress talking about high performance
computing
and the kind of things that you find in
there are recommendations for funding
it's like we think we should fund high
performance computing 638 million
dollars
it's like okay that's pretty serious
that's
yeah okay so
so and this was like a multi-agency
thing it's like nsf and nasa doe and
like all these different
different agencies so
i could i could see where maybe the nasa
people were coming from it's like
200 million dollars permission
maybe okay like yeah okay maybe that's a
legitimate question like who gave you
permission to do python on if it's if
it's within this framework but
the uh the problem is that we're not in
this framework
let me talk about the framework that we
were we were in this is peter this is
peter baumdahl
he was uh condensed matter of physicist
already red flags should be going up
physics
leave that
um so so peter uh
primarily was in a group producing
physics papers
that was the primary thing we wrote lots
of papers physics papers
however um
peter was also the group system
administrator
i think it was like a real gear head he
just loved computers and like fooling
around with code and stuff like that so
he was the assistant men for the group
which was very unusual most physics
people are not going to be the system so
he he managed the sun workstations and
other stuff and that meant that he also
knew how to set up networks and
connections and other
other things but
this idea of networks
is sort of more than just machines but
by being a system administrator he was
sort of plugged in
to the computing
group
at the lab so to speak there were a lot
of people doing computing like other
system admins and other things and so
he had access
at sort of a personal level to
some very advanced parts of the lab uh
specifically the advanced computing lab
and the advanced computing lab is where
they had things like connection machines
so in 1989 as the
the lab had a connection machine too
this is what it looks like and
that was sort of set up to sort of as a
test bed for doing programming and then
one of the one of the kind of dirty
secrets about those machines
is that they often said idle
i asked peter about this and um it turns
out if you wanted to do something on the
cm2 it was easy to do that because
nobody wanted to program it it was like
really weird to program had 65 000
processors on it and like it's like
it was too hard to code people are using
craze and so he could get access to that
without any official approval it was
more like a tolerated access like now
you want to use it though go ahead
so um
so i had access and by having access
that actually allowed
access through various upgrades
at one point the machine was upgraded to
a connection machine 5 and then later to
some craze and some other other advanced
machines and again this was all kind of
i wouldn't say under the table it wasn't
really approved you know it's not not an
official
project that peter was working on here
but
one of the things that was kind of going
on is you know we would produce data
sets that the computing division would
like like you take data sets and then
it's like oh we could make cool pictures
out of that and then those cool pictures
would end up on the covers of
newsletters and things and it's like oh
it's like so the computing division is
looking good right it's like oh yeah
we're doing this great stuff on this
machine
these pictures and
but we didn't have funding i mean peter
did not have funding to do a software
project um
you know it's essentially the funding
for any of this it was it was more of a
side project to a material science
project we were supposed to be studying
dislocations in materials
and even that was kind of a side project
that was funded under something known as
an ldrd grant which
in in tech terms
this might be like a 20 project like
sometimes you hear about tech companies
and you go you have like your 20
spare time you get to do what you want
ldrd was kind of like that except that
you could get a little bit of funding
for it like you could submit a proposal
saying hey i want to work on this thing
and if it got approved you get a little
bit of money but it was
this whole thing was like a it was like
a side project to a side project using
somebody else's computer that we didn't
pay for and i don't know they just kind
of liked us and so forth so
so this is this is kind of the framework
that uh that
was in play is it sort of peter peter
loved all um
i entered the picture of this as a grad
student so i i was a grad student at the
time peter and i did most of the coding
i was primarily doing coding um
my sort of entry to this was through the
student programs at the lab the lab
hired thousands of summer students to do
various things and i came out of that
uh peter actually later admitted to me
that he was sort of reluctant to have a
student
like it was sort of forced on him he's
like i don't really want a summer
student and like people
you know people in the group are like
nah you should take a summer student we
got all these thousands of students they
got to do something he's like okay i'll
pick a summer student
and it turns out i had already been a
summer student
before i had worked on some software
to do radiation safety training of all
things um and that was written in modula
2.
and peter actually told me later he's
like the reason i called you is that you
were the only summer student who didn't
list fortran as a skill that you knew
he's like i just hated fortran he's like
no modula two i'm gonna call the modular
two guys so so i kind of ended and ended
up in this group
sort of out of the blue with this weird
modula 2 background just because peter
didn't want to fortran and and so we
kind of kind of worked together uh some
other uh some other people in the group
um we had a bunch of post-docs niels
tim suja pablo these were physics
post-docs fairly independent
i would say that they kind of sat near
peter
would be their main kind of claim to
fame here okay so but we interacted with
them it's like you know interactive
postdocs and then we had some other
interactions across the lab mostly with
like computational chemistry
computational chemistry physics
um the leader of this whole show was um
allen bishop this is a kind of group
director
he was very hands-off
uh he was one of these guys where it's
like i guess we should have a group
meeting once a year
oh okay once a year
reluctantly it's like so he was very
hands-off um he basically left peter
alone uh there was kind of an unders he
sort of tolerated what peter was doing
he's like he didn't quite understand it
maybe but he's like i see what you guys
are doing it looks it looks good i'll
just kind of let you do what you want
and i'll protect you in a way so i think
allen in some sense was maybe kind of a
protector of what was going on but this
was not
this was not what i would call kind of
like a really well organized effort so
so in answering that question to nasa
you know permission it's like
what are you talking about permission
this is like a side project with two
people there's no permission here um
i mean this
this thing doesn't even exist in any
kind of reality there's like you know no
funding for software and so forth so
so i so i kind of go into this because i
think this is
also kind of mirrors how python was
created if you look at the history of
python
it was never funded
it's like guido you know keto started as
like a christmas break project
kind of on his own and it sort of
sort of existed inside the scope of
other projects um
uh they had a big uh ceremony for dito
about two years ago um
celebrating the 30 years of python i was
at that it sounded like like guido was
almost like a rogue agent just kind of
went off and made this programming
language and like his his supervisor was
on sabbatical or something it's just
like
permission i mean it's like permission
has is is not i would not say it's part
of python's dna to ask permission okay
so
so we we fit like right into that
you know permission okay so
so so so
that is kind of the framework that we're
operating is is that now
now i'm going to talk about some other
things
that were going on at this time march
1994.
the beast
what am i talking about the beast here
okay the beast um
the beast in this project was the
connection machine 5. very cool looking
machine there's a video of it in
operation lots of blinking lights it's
all black
cool it's like oh yeah awesome
it was sort of punishing the program i
mean just what we're what we're talking
about here is it's a it's a thousand
processor machine
each processor had 32 gig of ram did
about 128 gigaflaps had 500 gig of disk
storage i'm a little bit i look at that
i'm like that's just crazy because i was
taunting my kids two years ago walking
around with my phone going like a 512
gig on my iphone and
kids hate it so
so you know 500 gig of storage but this
is what you could get for 30 million
dollars
in 1992. was that um
it was sort of weird to program had
vector units and a lot of cindy stuff
you could program it in fortran and hope
that and just sort of hope for the best
um
you could also program it in c
but honestly a lot of people programmed
it in assembler
like fortran plus assembly or c plus
assembly if you got into that you had to
read these like very sort of dense books
i actually have one here the connection
machine vector unit
processing guide here yeah like the kind
of stuff that you'd find in there
where like memory maps and other other
things and you'd have to program it in
kind of a mix of assembler and see
macros
it's just terrible you know so so not
not fun to program but that's how you
got performance off out of it and
as a you know as a sort of a story on
that um
we were not the only ones kind of
playing around with assembly i remember
going to the
connection machine 5 user group 80
maybe a 93 a few hundred people showed
up for that i remember
some physics you know another physics
person working on quantum promo dynamics
got up and said yeah i wrote
i wrote 20 000 lines of assembly code
for the connection machine and every and
everybody in the audience just was
horrified like you're a lunatic you're
crazy and then
and then
you know it was like everybody was
shocked but then what you know sort of
sort of after that guy talked
um
larry smarr from
ncsa
of
the web browser
you know ncsa got up and did a demo of
mosaic
it was one of the first demos of mosaic
like everybody thought mosaic was like
so cool they forgot about the assembly
guys
oh the mosaic we want to find out more
about that so
so that is um you know what was going on
there um
another thing that was going on and this
is really going to be kind of weird is
that there was a very big focus on
performance
like
you really wanted to push the envelope
on this machine like
like how fast can we make this machine
work um at the time
i was taking computer architecture
at unm
new mexico and i was working on a
project i'd written like a cash
simulator and i was like i was trying to
figure out how to do better cash
performance or something this is a
diagram from that i remember going to
class one day and i come back from class
and peter's like hey i was on the news
for cars there he is on the news let me
let me just play it for a second chips
materials of all kinds
i see us being able to to
we haven't even dreamt about you know
using computers before that's really
what our facilities okay let me let me
pause that for a second so i come back
from class and peter's like yeah i was
on the news i was like oh interesting
what what news where were you at and
he's like i mean you couldn't remember
he's like he comes like like cbn there's
no like cbs i'm like no no no not cbs
like no
okay and i don't know it sounded kind of
weird and
um
on a hunch i actually called a
friend i don't know whether i recorded
this or not but we set a timer to record
the record this on the video tape i mean
this is getting 94 right so
this video that you're watching is is
off videotape from kind of me calling
somebody on a whim and then
ending up with it so let me play it for
a little bit longer to respond to those
challenges and drive those new
environments to let us solve those
problems in ways we couldn't do before
science is moving ahead so quickly that
even the top scientists here at cbs
national laboratory tell us they have to
constantly adjust to the latest
developments in science
the question is how well can the general
public adjust to those same developments
as they enter everyday life
reporting from los alamos new mexico i'm
galen tethrow cbn news it's
mind-boggling now i have to pause this
for a second and say that that this
particular newscast caused a certain
amount of amusement
at the lab if you know about the 700
club um in in the us this is basically a
tele evangelist
program pat robertson was like
presidential candidate
um
so
peter ended up on on on this program and
if you go to the the youtube link you
can see more but one of the things that
kind of ended up with that this is
amazing is there was the super computing
fact sheet that came out
about the los alamos show the super
computers how would you change their
life and in the fact sheet
it talks about the bees
this is why it was called the beast we
had like this so a pete i don't know how
much how long we gave peter lots of
like flack about this like reading about
this interview
but the uh the cm5 being called the
beast just sort of seemed totally
appropriate given all the assembly
language and the horrible programming
and other stuff and then
in a really weird turn of events um it
turns out that the
code for us that had the assembly in it
was in a file with 666 lives um
not it is weird i is like how does this
actually happen in in reality anyway the
beast the connection machine five
uh was something you know for the most
part people you know it demanded respect
right you know it's like okay kind of
hard to program um
you gotta program it in real programming
languages like fortran or assembly or c
or something like that and
and
needless to say
people were not happy when i put python
on it a couple years later at one point
we were running the python repo on this
machine on 512 processors and people
found out about it
and they were actually kind of angry but
they're they were like you're running
the rebel i'm
at the interactive rebel on half of the
connection machine just like
sitting there
[Music]
i think the i think the beast was fine
with it but some of the people counting
dollars were sort of like
we don't know whether it was like that
so
so anyway that's that that's that's the
beast now
in understanding that last
that last slide um
how did we even end up putting python on
this thing i mean it's sort of an
unlikely turn of events right it's like
python this language created by guido on
christmas vacation named after monty
python
ending up on ending up on the bees
like how does that happen okay so
this this question of how to find python
um
we basically found it through some
popular publication so one of the
publications of that time was computers
and physics this is a
a picture of computers and physics i
actually have that here
the same same issue that's actually our
work on the cover that's um a picture
that we made 1993 peter and i from from
even before this this you know kind of
the early stages of that so we had we
had a cover photograph on computers and
physics
turns out in computers and physics there
was a
column scientific program
where you'd find things like this like
how to write nearly portable fortran
programs okay well maybe that one didn't
quite appeal to us yeah you're on your
own with that
but the editor of this column was um
somebody named paul dubois
at lawrence livermore national
laboratory actually a competitor to us
at los alamos right okay so
paul dubois
and paul was um
very much had his finger on the pulse of
a lot of programming topics he was very
interested in scientific programming and
he would often write about new things
coming out in fact in the same issue
where he had the cover paul had a little
you know he has like a little commentary
and he's saying hey
we're going to learn pearl next time
1993.
it's like i'll bring you up to speed on
pearl excellent pearl i'm actually kind
of glad that paul was maybe not more
successful in that you know maybe we
would all be doing this conference in
pearl if if it if he had but paul was
actually talking about a lot of
you know a lot of stuff related to
programming
one of the um one of the common themes
about what paul was talking about was
the idea of making programs
programmable or making physics
applications programmable so this is an
article from 1994 the same magazine
and he writes about this vision you know
i mean you know imagine writing physics
codes and fortran
okay you have to forgive that a little
bit but controlling them with something
else you know some kind of high level
thing right you know like a like a high
level programming language we can create
variables and loops and
and so forth and this is this is 1994
this is exactly the kind of thing we're
doing with python yeah
all these extensions like numpy they're
in nc we're controlling it from python
so he was he was talking about this in
94
and
i learned about python through that
column this is january
1996 and it's maybe one of the earliest
um you know one of the earliest mentions
of python it could find but it was just
in a blur
it was in his like little commentary up
on the sides like python one three has
been released and then it had this
description of you know oh you do see
extensions and dynamically load it you
can embed it and i was like oh that
sounds really awesome to me because i
was actually working on a different
project
at that time called swig
some of you may have encountered swig so
we had not been out all that long but it
was something i was already working on
in another context i was like ooh python
what's that oh that sounds cool so
a couple months after this showed up
that's when python got added to the
to the so-called sweet project now
whether it was good or not i don't know
i mean you can see my commentator
commentation down here about oh it's a
clue and like i might have to rewrite it
or something but
this is um
that's where it showed up
some other things that are happening at
this time um may of that same year 96 is
when numeric python actually got written
about
this is the predecessor to numpy and
some of the other extensions you have
paul and conrad hinson and james hugin
and some people
in that same magazine talking about
um you know the numeric part of python
and
they are talking about the earlier
article the 1994 article saying hey
python is really well suited for this
programmable physics id
it's a scripting language you bring
compiled code into it this is great now
we're doing we're doing
doing numerics okay so
that was that was going on and then in
june of 96 you had the fourth
international python conference which
was held at lawrence livermore national
labs this is in paul dubois like
backyard
and
so you had the the fourth international
python conference um
this small conference about 50 people
i was i was at that it was maybe 50
people it was actually
behind the fence at lawrence livermore
meaning it was like in a secure area and
it required like background checks and
all this stuff and we got a we actually
got a big tour of the laser facility on
it it was it was crazy but that uh that
conference um
had a lot number of talks about science
with python like scientific graphics
package for python
python with graphics more you know more
graphics visualization
python with numeric you know numeric
python and physics and stuff so these
ideas were
really front and center at this
conference there were some there are
some web programmers there too so it was
a real weird mix of like web programmers
and physics people but
that that conference
really set up a lot of themes about what
people were thinking about graphics
visualization data analysis problem
solving in science um
one um
one thing at this time i'll just i'll
just mention it
there was no interest really
in
programming
per se like the topic was not really
python as a programming language it was
more like oh how can we use python to do
this other stuff
like visualization that's that's what we
want to do what's that so
if anything it would this this maybe
would be a precursor to like jupiter
notebooks or something it's like yeah
i'm gonna solve all these problems so
so that that was
what was what was going on um in 96 now
i had just mentioned that i was working
on this swig press
and it's and it's
i want to say a little bit more about
that i have to back up a year to get
into that to june 1995.
in june 1995
i had just finished my first year of
graduate school and um i came back to
work with with peter and
peter had sort of entered i don't know a
stage of doom and by doom
i mean doom 2
the video game doom 2. um as it as it
turns out
peter was was i don't know he was going
through some personal things that that
summer i mean like many of us do
sometimes you know it's like that that
happens and for whatever reason did you
know peter was just like dave
just do whatever you want
i'm kind of checking out for the summer
and
and honestly it's like his door was
closed a lot and when the door was
closed he was playing doom 2 in the
office okay so that and i was like okay
fine peter you played playing dude too i
actually could not really blame him that
much because i had just spent like the
previous two months playing marathon on
the mac trying to avoid thinking about
my qualifying exams in graduate school
okay so it's it's like mine okay you
want to play doom 2.
that's that that's cool okay so it's
kind of a kind of a weird summer you
know doom 2 video games um now
getting to going back to my graduate
school experience um i
again was in my first year of graduate
school at the university of utah
and
mostly i was taking classes okay i was
not doing research wasn't doing any
projects but i was sort of attached to
chris johnson who was a you know
professor at university of utah very
well known for visualization and other
other um
other things and so chris was working
with a graduate student steve parker on
this um this visualization system called
skiron now
skiron was like the epitome of flashy i
mean this was something that ran on
these sgis it was really cool i mean
it's like you could like rotate like fly
around data and do all these things at
this big visual programming environment
it was really
it was really kind of awesome actually i
mean and later just later on chris like
the group actually built this whole kind
of thing around ski run and
chris ended up being my advisor but i i
was more of a i don't know more of a
side project to ski run okay so i kind
of worked in this framework but
this is
a good example
of where that 630 million dollars was
going i mentioned the the big funding
for computing that
that money
was basically everywhere i mean it was
at the universities it was at the labs
it was over multiple agencies and and
projects like that these like really
fancy visualization projects that just
attracted money like crazy it's like
yeah we want that and and los alamos was
um you know sort of sort of part of that
too i mean we had a lot of very fancy
hardware like expensive silicon graphics
machines
they actually little signs on it because
they would often bring like tour groups
in there you know like oh let's bring
some high school kids into the computing
centers
silicon graphics and then you know they
do these demos and all this stuff it's
like okay awesome okay so we had
machines with like lots of demos
these were sort of hooked up to super
computers using very expensive
networking like los alamos developed its
own network like high-speed interconnect
to connect super computers and build
like whole creative super computers and
other
other other things around that uh there
was also um
kind of an emphasis on the software side
you know let's do object-oriented
programming c plus plus big software
kinds of projects so the the 600 million
dollars all around
people doing big computing computing
kinds of things and and so
one sort of weird thing about this is
just how did it intersect with us
okay keep in mind we've got peter
condensed matter physics
and
it didn't really intersect with us
directly
at all this is this is more how it
intersected um we had certain
collaborators
at the lab
to protect their identity i'm going to
call one of them pinky it's not their
real name but we would kind of
collaborate and eat lunch with pinky and
then like i would join pinky for lunch
as well because what am i gonna do so we
go to lunch
and then uh you know pinkie as it turns
out was married to mabel who sort of
worked over in the applied physics
division as an application programmer
and mabel also would sometimes come to
lunch you know and you know kind of fill
us in what's going on over in applied
physics and
so she was you know kind of a user of
the c-plus plus for scientific computing
crowd so the big project over in applied
physics and we got
sort of a lot of inside information
about how well that was going it was it
was usually things like yeah it's some
kind of template hell and it doesn't
compile
and we can't debug it with anything
except print
and everybody hates it
it's like oh it's just constant horror
show stories coming out of this project
and so
again we weren't really involved with
that but we kind of
kind of looked at that and it was like
wow i mean i don't know what they're
doing but we definitely don't want to do
that
it's got to be some better
you know
you know better better way to do that so
so you know we were sort of exposed to a
lot of these things but
in some sense we wanted to go against
the grain a little bit and so
so so that was going on just as an aside
by the way
if you flash forward several years later
it turns out that some very important
individual
woman called buffy
not their real name over in applied
physics uh in charge of this thing oh
also by the way um
applied physics
at los alamos is a euphemism for nukes
i'm not going to sugarcoat that so this
was coming out of certain division of
los alamos okay buffy was in charge of
that
um
heard about
what we're doing
with the python stuff and he's and he's
and he's like
okay let's have a meeting buffy and
peter have a meeting
uh as part of that it was sort of found
out that we didn't have any funding
this whole thing was like a side project
to a side project and the story as i
understand it from peter is that as part
of that meeting um he found out that
buffy actually really kind of liked the
python stuff it's like wow that's really
cool what you're doing
here's some monopoly money actually
literal monopoly money handed to peter
who he was then told give it to my
secretary on the way out the door
and it showed up as funding to keep
supporting some of the molecular
dynamics work so
so trying to figure out like the can you
know it's like that that comment about
this not existing as a project it's like
it's crazy it's like
it's like a side project to a side
project that's now liked by somebody
with just throwing money around out of
the applied physics division that's like
wow okay
crazy
but
ignoring that it's like okay okay it's
like where okay what was i talking about
here
okay june june 1995 okay i got to back
up to june 1995.
i'm kind of sitting in this situation
thinking wow this is really great
everything that's going on it's like
peter wanting to play doom everything
broken everybody went into c plus and
like
stuff like so it's like you know
what what am i going to do for this
project and and peter basically say oh
yeah just do whatever you want
i don't know just leave me alone go i
don't know go do whatever you want so
coming out of graduate school um i had
learned certain topics i took a course
on compilers
that was that was pretty cool i took
some system stuff operating systems
networks
systems programming i taken a class on
ml program this is not machine learning
by the way this is the ml programming
language which is very advanced type
systems functional programming kind of
things
i was thinking about all that stuff it's
like what am i going to do with all with
all of that and this summer and i was
like you know what i'm going to do i'm
going to blow up ster toke
and get on
you're like stir tokyo get up what is
that about um so it turns out these
physics codes
were almost always these batch
processing jobs
you control it with a script this is how
we control their code like 1994 looked
like that it was terrible i was like i
gotta get rid of that
so what i wanted to do was just get rid
of the batch processing stuff
and put a scripting interface on it
and
i ended up doing that i wrote a
scripting language for the physics code
that was kind of my own creation now
part of the reason for doing this is
that the connection machine was just
such a weird machine that
you basically could not port code to it
i mean it's like you wanted to use it
you had to write it you know it was like
okay i'll write a scripting language
did i care about programming languages
no i did not care about making a
programming language like
i it's like
what i was trying to do
was this i wanted a scripting interface
i could take my physics code and then
add some components to it like
visualization and debugging some other
stuff this is exactly the thing that
paul dubois was talking about a year
earlier in the in the computers and
physic
i was not aware of that at the time by
the way if i had i probably maybe would
have changed what i what i had done but
you know sort of same idea you know kind
of controlling things with scripting um
and really what i was trying to do is
just
kill the whole right hand side of that
diagram it's like i didn't want to deal
with the data files and the sgi and the
ftp and all that stuff it's like enough
of that i want to do something else with
that
so that was the um
that was the vision i ended up
abandoning it when i came back to
graduate school because i told them hey
i wrote a programming language and then
they were immediately like no you didn't
forget about that idea right now that's
not happening so okay so
then it turned it turns out there were
other stuff out there like tickle tk and
pearl and i found python and and you
know and python was great i mean we
liked the syntax of it the rebel sold it
you know it's like oh the other rebel i
want that definitely want that you could
interface it with c code
using you know swig and some other other
things and then
the other thing is the implementation
was pretty clean it was written in c had
few dependencies and
one
one thing that we were really into is we
wanted to be able to hack it
we found it something that you could
hack and make it by by hacking it meant
that you could put it on the connection
with a bit of work and so that was
really
you know that's that's really what we
saw on it i think there was something
else kind of in play though and
i think this is something that paul
dubois really had some insight on as
well which is
it would be much more powerful to be
involved with a community of tool
builders
than just to make your own custom tool
off on the side and
and and
i agree with that i mean i think one of
the things that we kind of saw in python
is that python could serve as kind of a
common glue
for building a lot of stuff and then if
people gave it away you'd be able to be
able to use that right it's like and and
you can also sell it a little bit better
right because it's like oh we're not
making our own programming language
we're doing python
it's like a tool so
i think i think that was useful and and
and
just as an example of some of the tool
building i thought i would talk about
the visualization system that we that we
made for this thing um
it was very much kind of a
do-it-yourself attitude that was one of
the goals of being able to do this it's
like oh physics people you can make your
own tools
and so
we were kind of operating with some
constraints i mean basically every
every node of this parallel computer was
a 32 megabyte machine
and we were trying to basically embed
visualization and scripting into it and
we were very concerned about kind of the
efficiency of this and doing it very
cheaply and not
not having a lot of code and um so we
built this visualization system and
here's here's what it looked like this
this might blow your mind um one of the
tools that we used on the workstation
was this image viewer called xv
i don't know if anybody uses that now
it's probably really dated but it's like
this great kind of image tool
um so we took that we had the source
code for xd
and i ripped out the gif encoder out of
xv and i put it into the physics code
just doing cut and paste of ceco so i
saw i
took the you know took the jif encoder
and put it into physics as an aside uh
the compression algorithm in jif at that
time was the subject of patent
litigation and i knew that but i kind of
figured if they want to come out after a
lab with nuclear weapons they could do
okay so we we kept the kept the
compression around um
i had written a graphics library as part
of the radiation safety project from
1990 so i still had that code so i took
that and kind of adapted it to the
connection machine and then
using some system stuff we hooked it up
with sockets and built this like image
server thing that would feed xv so like
a whole lot of pieces kind of don't know
kind of slapped together that might
there's actually not a whole lot of code
there but it was just sort of glued
together stuff
and then we took some code from the
computing division that previously been
on the sgi and kind of adapted it and
then slapped a scripting interface on it
and then tied the whole thing together
and and it was awesome i mean it was
sort of hacked together but what used to
take hours was reduced down to like two
seconds
and it just blew people's mind this is
what it looked like not not real fancy
but you would essentially do a lot of
like terminal windows with xv
displays sort of shown and then it kind
of operated in the same way that people
might use like a jupiter notebook in a
way you know it's like interactive
computing and you can like do plots and
see things
so for you also
you know at one point one of the one of
the post docs he was like hey is there
some way i can monitor the code on the
super computer while it's running i was
like yeah i'll put a web browser in it
so i used python's web browser module
just to open up a like a socket on one
of the connection machine nodes and then
he could uh
he was able to access that at home over
a modem
and then see like images coming off the
connection machine i don't think the
computing division ever knew that we had
an open network port on the
supercomputer that was accessible just
to the outside world so
times are different different different
there
um just to give an idea like how um
like how effective this this was um
this is sort of an unusual story as well
um so i was i was back at the university
of utah
and at utah somebody had decided that
three times t1 is equal to t3
as it obviously is
by the math
and
in doing that math they kind of observed
that
why if that's true why is t3 costing 45
000 a month
we should get rid of t3 that's stupid
why would we get why would we pay for t3
well we could have t1 3 times t1
not realizing that these were actually
network connections
of different bandwidths um at that time
a t3 connection was a 45 megabit per
second connection
and whereas one was a 4.5 megabit
connection university of utah actually
got rid of their 45 megabit network
connection and put the entire university
of 28 000 students on a 4.5 megabit
internet connection and
the uh the
bandwidth just dropped off the cliff
when that happened um but one of the
things that happened is my little
visualization system with the jiff files
worked great
it was it was like yeah i can still
access los alamos and i can still do
these visualizations and people it blew
people's minds they're like wow even
though this completely
is terrible it's still
it still works uh as a funny postscript
to that it took you it took the
university six months to get their
internet connection back because the uh
the provider gave it to somebody else
and to get a new connection they had to
run fiber from cheyenne wyoming which is
about 400 miles away we had to wait six
months for it so
truly terrible situation
on the on the los alamos side um the
system led to a lot of papers that's
what we wanted to do anyway was write
physics papers and
it really enabled people to do that so
it was it was it was pretty it was
pretty awesome to kind of to see this
system kind of
kind of in in play
this kind of a random note but the the
molecular dynamics software was later
adapted to study
pandemics
pandemics
specifically the h1n1 slime flu or
whatever that was from like 2005
and i actually saw it on the news uh in
if last year when they went when they
had that whole thing about the pandemic
like simulation like i don't know
everybody was like dunking on these
simulators like these pandemic
researchers there was part of me it's
like oh please god let that not be our
code i do not like i do not
think thankfully it was not us you know
i thought that would
you know the molecular code actually got
got adapted
believe it or not so
anyway this this this story we're almost
at kind of at the end here this
definitely was not just us um if you
look at a lot of the origin stories of
things in python it's kind of a similar
story this is from the sixth python
conference 1997. conran hinson
talking about molecular modeling uh if
you read about that it's kind of a
similar story it's like here's a tool
written by a single person over a year
part-time
i don't think he has permission and i
don't know whether he had much funding i
mean it sounds like a you know sounds
like a part-time project
same thing with some of the the tools we
use now ipython
i was a grad student using python
don't think he asked permission i don't
doubt he had funding for this it sounds
like uh you know it's like this is just
something cool i want to work on and
and and that's that's what i'm doing so
a lot of stuff like this kind of in this
time period it's like people you know
kind of doing things on the side not a
lot not almost no funding no permission
or
or anything and there's a lot of stories
that are kind of you know kind of
similar to that so
now now to kind of wrap this up you know
i'm looking at the clock near the end
here i want to talk about some some lies
that we used to tell people in working
on this stuff
um first of all python was not something
that people were into like if you had to
sell this to higher up they're like no
what are you what are you doing and
there were all sorts of things that that
would be told like it's a prototype
or it's throwaway code
we'll rewrite it yeah we'll rewrite it
in c
or it's optional yeah it's optional um
the optional thing is actually one of
the things that we did in our project
because um what we tried to do is we're
like yeah you get rid of the batch
processing and you put the scripting
interface on and it's it's like it's
basically the same and this tool that i
had written called swig was kind of part
of that where it would take like c
header files and then just build like a
python interface from it we would tell
people oh just use that
and uh the whole reason it was released
was actually with the hope of subverting
another science project
to do scripting we thought scripting was
great we're like oh man we could really
mess up these projects by providing like
an open source tool to let them do what
we were doing and so
that was that was kind of some of the
motivation for that to
i don't know infect other other projects
as well another another strategy that
was kind of also in place you would tell
people that others were doing it
this is something that that that paul
dubois did actually this is sort of
sort of interesting to see but um paul
invited me out to livermore in july 1996
and um
had me give a talk about steering
or steering physics codes at los alamos
and
the pitch that i gave at los alamos was
exact basically what i just what i just
described um actually i'll i'll play
this you can listen for a minute here
i'll talk about it
so one of the ways so the way that we or
at least the way we approach this is we
started playing around with scripting
languages last year
and the idea was
we would take our original molecular
dynamics code shown over here on the
left
and what we would do is we would add
sort of a scripting language to the
front of it for controlling it
so the way that that worked is we would
we basically took our original
application put this this new front end
on it that was an interpreted language
and then once we had that we started
adding new modules so we added some
things to do data analysis we had to do
some things to do visualization
we added some networking code to send
information back to a user's workstation
and kind of the idea was you would have
the original you'd leave the original
molecular dynamics code about the same
okay leave the code the same that was
probably the big the big message it's
like we're trying to like trying to
corrupt people it's like hey you could
do the scripting stuff and leave it the
same but do all this other stuff
um the reason that this talk even exists
is
paul had paul dubois was in the audience
he had me come out there and i think
what his purpose was was to tell the
livermore people
look at the los alamos people because
livermore and los alamos kind of enemies
of each other
like oh look what they're doing how come
we're not doing that i don't actually
know whether paul
understood that it was just like two
people
doing it on a side project i mean maybe
he did but it was not presented in that
way when we were out there so maybe i
don't maybe it's like a propaganda piece
or something okay so
um so so
that is kind of at the end of the talk
here um now some things that i kind of
kind of think about okay getting to the
end python has really uh kind of is
ascendant right now python is number one
go python all right good good you know
and i think about you know where python
is right now um but i also think about
this story i mean this story that
described this is 26 years ago
and
if i go back 26 years and i look at
things like c programming it was only 23
years old c was from 1972.
python right now is 31 years old
you've seen this xkcd about the
environments right you know and it's
like look at python it's like huh
i think about you know what's going on
with python and i think about the future
of what's happening with python but um
instead of thinking about the future of
python i sort of wonder whether there's
a successor to python and i honestly
don't know but if you think about this
you know this story i mean and what we
ended up building in some sense was a
successor to see
and to fortran and a bunch of tools i
mean we didn't totally give up those
tools but we're you know thinking about
like a different approach so
i think about this future and i think
about
you know this question is history
something that repeats itself
are we in a situat you know is there you
know is something to emerge out of this
is there stuff going on are there
students in postdocs working on new
stuff right now and if they are what are
they studying
and what problems are they solving that
are different than what we're doing are
they doing something better than what
we're doing right now
and who's providing the environment for
doing that
and who's getting the word out i mean a
lot of these things kind of went to you
know
went together you know and and
you know i see in the chat somebody
commenting about julia
maybe it is
i don't know i don't have any particular
thoughts about any specific thing but i
i think about these kinds of questions
and how
python kind of
took over the science world kind of you
know
through different means there and so
those are questions to think about and i
think they're worth thinking about for
other people as well so that's the end
of the talk um i you know admittedly
went a little over a few minutes that
i'd hope there but i'll see if there's
some questions that people want to ask
and
yeah david thank you very much for your
interesting talk we don't have any
questions in the q a just yet we have
about two more minutes if there's anyone
with a question you can ask it in the q
a okay
so hoping for some extra questions again
thank you very much for your time it was
very very interesting
and i see uh azaya also asked what would
you do differently in this week today if
you talked about that anyway oh
god differently in swing i
i have no well i have no idea i mean
maybe this is gonna be a i i have so
this is gonna be a really bad answer but
i have like so much post traumatic
stress from c plus plus
that
maybe i wouldn't do that the second
times the second time around although
i'm not you know maybe maybe swing would
not have been successful at all if it
hadn't done c plus plus
all right i think that's all we have
time for so thank you very much again
david and
thank you for being here and i hope for
all the participants that they enjoy the
rest of the conference
okay thank you